ก็ไม่คด
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครู
ฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 18
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะปี
ข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7-11
พอดีเดือนเดือน
พฤษภาคม AE ผช
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศเต๊ตปีพ 2  0  2  2 ค่ะค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 19 ค่ะเดือนเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ยี่ห้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา
13:00 นบ่ายโมงกี่นาที
23 นาทีค่ะมีเลข 5 ชั่วโมง
13 นาทีรูปฟ้า
กลางวันนะเป็นตอนบ่ายแล้วนะคะตอนบ่ายค่ะ
วันนี้ค่ะครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไรก็ไปค่ะวันนี้ครูหญิงน่ะคะ
จะมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฟ้า
เกมอะไรคะครูหญิงเอ้าครูฟ้านะคะอันนี้ครู
ฟ้า
สมัครไม่ได้นะคะกูฟ้าเนี่ยมีหู
นี้ครูหญิง
ค้าผู้หญิงในไซส์หัวเล็กๆก็พอหรอพี่ต้อง
มีปาดใหญ่ๆ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็จะพูดนะพูดพูดคำก็มี 1  2
จะมีรูปนะฮะอันเนี้ยเป็นรูปแต่ครูฟาไม่
รู้ว่ามันคืออะไร
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะพูดอ้ะ 1  2  3 ครูฝาเนี่ย
ฟังฟัง 1 ครูฟ้าฟังเสร็จครูฟ้าจะต้องคิด
สิ่งที่พูดว่าน่ากลัวเหมือนกันเนาะครูฟ้า
ก็นั่งคิดต้องคิดนะคะว่าอันนี้เนี่ยคือ
อะไร
[เพลง]
หรือจะมีคำใบ้ให้ 1  2  3  3 นะคะสีจะบอก
ทีเดียวเลยนะ 3 ครูฟ้าฟังเสร็จแล้วก็คิด
อะไร
ครูฟ้าพร้อมไหมคะพร้อมค่ะครูก็จะเดี๋ยว
ถ้าผีศพปัดแม่นะคะมันจะมีรูปอยู่อยู่รูป
ที่ 1 นะข้อที่ 1 นะคะรูปที่ 1 นะนายค่ะ
อันนี้เป็นรูปแล้วกันเนาะคำใบ้ที่ 1
ราคะอันนี้เนี่ย
ของอันนี้นะคะซื้อสิ่งนี้เนี่ยมันเป็นวง
กลม
วงกลม
แล้วก็สอง
ของอันนี้หรือว่าสิ่งนี้นะคะ
ร้อนนะร้อน
ร้อนก็อาจจะซักอุดรไปนะคะ 5
40-50 ศาเซลเซียสเนี่ย
ร้อนนะคะร้อน
3  3
อ่า
ของอันนี้นะคะ
สว่างทำไมเหมือนครูฟ้ามีบ้านใช่ไหมตอน
กลางคืนตอนกลางคืนน่ะมันมืดใช่มั้ยมองไม่
เห็นแต่ว่าของอันนี้เนี่ยเวลาภูฟ้าเปิดไฟ
อันเนี้ยสว่าง
แต่ข้างนอกข้างนอก
ข้างนอกเป็นสีดำทำไมเป็นสีดำสีดำ
อันเนี้ยมืดมืดไม่แต่ข้างในบ้านครูฟ้า
เนี่ยสว่างนะของอันนี้เนี่ยมันสว่างกูฟ้า
คิดว่าเขาคือใครของสิ่งนี้คืออะไร
เป็นวงกลม
ร้อนแล้วก็สว่างทั่วฟ้าคิดว่ามันคืออะไร
ชื่อ
หลอดไฟลอง Five ครูฟ้าคิดว่าหลอดไฟอันนี้
ใช่ไหมอันนี้คือหลอดไฟไงผิดข้าคิด
ร้อน
ๆ
20  50 องศาแล้วผู้หญิงหญิงที่บอกเหรอ
อีกแล้วบอกคู่ฟ้าเหรอว่าหอมกูฟ้า 1 หาไม่
เห็นนะคะ
10000  1,000 สาเซลเซียสภูเขาก็รู้สิบอก
80 องศาร้อนเกินไปเพราะคิดถึง 80 องศา
เหรอดวงอาทิตย์ไม่ได้รู้ตู้
พระอาทิตย์แต่พาดีไม่ต้องร้อนเกิน 80
องศา
ร้อนๆโอเคๆต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
ของชิ้นต่อไปนะคะครูฟ้าก็คิดว่ารูปนี้นะ
รูปที่ 2 เนี่ยมันคืออะไร
คำใบที่ 1 ทำใบที่ 1 นะคะได้ค่ะต้นไม้
ต้นไม้
แล้วก็เพลงขยับนิดนึงนะมันไปถนนมากเกินไป
ต้นไม้นะคะทำไมที่ 1 นะต้นไม้ทำให้ที่สอง
สีน้ำตาล
นี่นะนี้เนอะ 4 น้ำตาล
[เพลง]
คำใบที่ 3
อะไรคะครูนา
รวย
หน้าลิง
โป้
ครูสอนลิงเป็นยังไงคะนักเรียนหรือเรียน
ไม่รู้อันนี้จริงของอ่ะลิงดูมากป๊าจะถูก
หรือผิด
ถูกเราถ้า
ลิงลิง
ค่ะทำไมลิงเนี่ยอยู่บนต้นไม้ใช้ตัวสีน้ำ
ตาลแล้วก็ชอบกินกล้วยมันคือนิ่งลิงค์เก่ง
วาด
รหัส
รูปต่อไปรูปที่ 4 นะคะรูปที่ 4 มันคือรูป
อ่ะอะไร
ทำใบที่ 1
โถเจ้าบอกว่าของอันนี้นะคะครูฟ้าสีเหลือง
ก็มีสีส้มมี
มี
สีแดงมี
สีฟ้ามี
สีเขียวมี
สีชมพูมีมีมีหลายสี
มีหลายสี
รู้แล้วหรอว่าคืออะไรยัง
โอเค
กูฟ้าบอกว่ารู้แล้วก็ไม่บอก
คำใบที่ 2
นี่มันข้อที่ข้อที่ 3 เองใช่ป่ะก็ข้อที่ 3
ใช่คนนึงผู้หญิงเขียนผิดขอโทรศัพท์ข้อที่
สามคำไม่ที่สอง
เสียงไมค์
สวยเวลามีหูหูของเราเนี่ยได้ยินใช่มั้ย
แบบ
เสียงดังก็คือมันเกิน 1  180 เดซิเบลไหม
อ่อน 180 เดสิเบลสมัยเนี่ยเสียงดัง
เวลาเสียงดังมาหาทำใบที่ 3
ลอยได้
รอยพระคุณจะทำไงให้มันแบบเหมือนแบบมันลอย
ได้อ่ะเหมือนเมฆอ่ะเหมือนเมฆใช่ไหมก้อน
เมฆเมฆเนี่ยลอยได้อยู่บนฟ้ามันลอยได้
อะไรมันคืออะไรมีหลายสีเสียงดังแล้วก็รอย
ได้เหมือนเมฆใช่มั้ยแม่เนี่ยลอย
มีหลายสีเสียงดังลอยได้ครูบ้านคิดว่ามัน
คืออะไร
โดนโดนอ่ะไม่ใช่โรน rhone เสียงดังหรอ
เรื่องจะโทรเนี่ยฮะเครื่องบินก็บินก็มี
วิ่งมีหลายสีหรอมีหลายสีแล้วคุยผู้สาวบอก
ว่าเครื่องบินเครื่องบินเนี่ยมันไม่ได้
ลอยได้เครื่องบินมันบินขอ
อะไรมันคือลูกโป่งฆ่า
มันเสียงดังยังไงอ่ะพี่เวลาครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
มีเข็มใช่ไหมแล้วก็ที่มันเวลาลูกโป่งมัน
แตกอ่ะมันเสียงดัง
อ่อนเวลาคุณทิ่มทุ่มเนี้ยดูมันแตกใช่ไหม
มันก็เสียงดัง
กูปานะผู้หญิงผูกใบไม่ดีหรือว่าเอ่อ
กไก่ค่ะครูป๋ารูปต่อไปนะคะอันนี้ของชิ้น
ที่ 4 นะคะว่ามันคืออะไรอ่ะทำไว้ที่ 1
ของอันนี้นะคะเป็นคู่เป็นคู่ก็คือมี 1  2
ต้องมีสองเป็นคู่นะคะเป็นผู้
คำใบที่สองหน้าของอันนี้เนี่ย
มันจะอยู่ในกล่องหนังเป็นคู่แล้วก็อยู่ใน
กล่อง 50 กล่องอยู่ในกล่องข้อที่ 3
เวลาจะใช้ของอันนี้นะคะของนี้มันก็จะมี
เชื่อสมัยมีเชื่อ
มีเชื่อต้อง Who นักแบบนี้นะมี
ข้อ 1 และก็ 2 เวลาจะใส่ไปใส่ไม่รู้แล้ว
เนี่ยต้องพูห์นะนี่คือการถูกต้องถูก
มันคืออะไร
รองเท้าครูฟ้าบอกว่ารองเท้า
ดูข่าว
แป๊บนึงขยับก่อนเก่งว่าไงสมัยรองเท้า
เนี่ยต้องใส่เป็นคู่มี 1 มี 1 มี 1 ข้าง
ได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ไม่ได้นะต้องเป็นคู่ค่ะมี
สอง
เวลาซื้อเวลาซื้อเนี่ยมันก็ต้องอยู่ใน
กล่องมันจะอยู่ในกรอบเวลาใส่ก็จะมีเชื่อ
เชื่อแล้วก็ผูกนะคะผูกเชือกเก่งมากเอง
ไปไหนหมดเวลานะอ่ะต่อไปนะคะของหรือว่าว่า
อะไรก็ไม่รู้นะชิ้นที่ห้านะคะมีอะไรเพราะ
บางอย่างมันก็ไม่ใช่ของใช่ไหม
ใช่คำใบที่ 1
สูง
สูงอาจจะ
มากกว่า 2 เมตร
สูง
ค่ะส่วนที่สุดให้ตัวส่งเมจริงๆๆสู่
คำใบที่ 2
นก
นกว่าเด็กอะ
นกอ่ะควีน
นี้เป็นนกมั้ยนก
ทำไมที่ 2 เนี่ยนก
คำใบที่ 3 เอ้อ
เอ่อ of ซิเจ้นถูกมั้ยได้ 2 อยู่ข้างล่าง
ถูกไหมกู to  2
of  Sin เล่นอ่ะทำไมที่ 1 สูงนะสูงคำไว้
ที่ 2 นกทำไว้ที่ 3 ออกซิเจนครูฟ้าคิดว่า
มันคืออะไร
ต้นไม้อ่ะกูฟ้าตอบว่าต้นไม้อ่าต้นไม้ดูสิ
คะว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบถูกหรือผิดถูกไหมคะ
Google
[เพลง]
ต้นไม้ทำไมต้นไม้เนี่ยสูงค่ะสูง 5 แล้วก็
นกนกเนี่ยชอบมาอยู่บนต้นไม้ใช่ไหมรกเนี่ย
รายการที่นี่นก
อยู่บนต้นไม้นะคะแล้วก็ต้นไม้เนี่ยให้
ออกซิเจนไม่มีออกซิเจนนะคะคิดถึงมากครู
ฟ้า
เก่งมากข้อต่อไปนะคะรูปหรือว่าของต่อรูป
ต่อไปเนี่ย 6 เนาะ
อบนะคะอ่ะคำใบที่ 1
ไม้ไม้สมัยมันไม้ต้นไม้เนี่ยเวลาที่เรามี
เรื่อย
ไปเรื่อยๆแล้วก็ตัดเนี่ยอัดมันก็จะเป็น
ไม้นะคะๆไม้
จะถึงวาดก่อนไม่รู้ว่าเป็นไม้หรือเปล่านะ
เนี่ยมาอย่างนี้บ๊ายนะไม้นะคะไม้นะคะคำใบ
ที่ 1 คำใบที่ 2
นิ้วมือ
เดี๋ยวตรงนี้และนิ้วกลางนิ้วนางนิ้วก้อย
นจริงๆเป็นครูหญิงฟังผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าไม่
รู้ว่ามันคืออะไร
นิ้วมึงเออทำไมที่ 3
เอ๊ยทำไมอ่ะ
ไม่มีเขียนไม่ได้ฟ้าออกผู้หญิงว่าประสบ
พร้อมเบิ้มออกอันนึงนะคะเดี๋ยวเขาผู้หญิง
เชื่อมปากกา Apple  Pencil ก่อนคำใบ้ที่ 3
ใบที่ 3
อายุอาวาสแต่คำไว้ที่ 3 เนี่ยเพลงสมัย
เพลง
เพลงๆเพลงนี้ก็ได้ใช่ไหมจะไม่ได้ร้องแต่
ว่ามีอันนี้แล้วก็มีอะไรเนี่ยตัวโน้ตฉัน
ผิดก็ว่าไม่ค่อยเป็นนะคะนักเรียนแล้วก็มี
โดเรถ้ามีอะไรเพลงรักของอันเนี้ยคืออะไร
ไหมคำไว้ที่ 1 ไม้เป็นไม้ทำจากไม้
2 นิ้วมือนิ้วมือ
แล้วก็ 3 เพลงกีต้าร์ค่ะกีต้าร์
เปล่าวะกีตาร์
กีตาร์นะคะกีตาร์ไปดูว่าใช่กีตาร์ไหม
รุจ
เปียโน
เปียโนมาแล้วกูมาชิป Piano
เปลี่ยนใจนะกีต้าร์ดีกว่านิ้วมือผัวต้อง
คิดถึงนิ้วมือกีตาร์เนี่ยมันใช้นิ้วก็
จริงแต่ว่ามันก็ใช้ปิ๊กให้ไหมแต่ Piano
เนี่ยคุณต้องใช้นิ้วมือ
ปัดเพียรหนูนาหนึ่งอะไรอีก 1 อันสุดท้าย
มาแล้วๆทำอะไรเนี่ยเอาอีกแล้วอ้าปากกาผู้
หญิงได้ดีแล้วหรือว่าหน้าจอ iPad ผู้หญิง
ได้ดีคะขิงใจเย็นๆนะความดาวอยากจะเย็นๆ
เย็นนะทำไมปากกาเขียนไม่ติดมาหาต่อไปนะคะ
ขอที่ 7 นะว่ารูปนี้มันคืออะไรคำว่าไอ้
ที่ 1 ค่ะสีทำไมเวลาดูเนี่ยเวลาดูเนี่ยมี
สีมีสีมีสีมีสีมีสีแล้วก็สวยสีสวยนะคะคำ
ใบที่ 2
จับจับไม่ได้
เรามีอันนี้อะไรก็ไม่รู้นะแล้วก็เรามีมือ
มือจับ
ไม่ได้จับไม่ได้ดูได้จะไม่ได้นะคะมีคำใบ
ที่ 3
แอปเปิ้ลเพนซิลผู้หญิงเป็นอะไร
หลุดตลอดเวลาเลยแบตจะหมดหรือเปล่าน่าจะทำ
ไว้ที่ 3
ห่าฝนตก
ฝนตก
เขาไม่ที่ 1 สีสวยคำไว้ที่ 2 จับไม่ได้ทำ
ใบที่ 3 ฝนตกมันคืออะไรคะครูฟ้า
สายรุ้งค่ะสายรุ้งสมัยที่มีหนึ่งแต่ช่าง
มันนะคะสายรุ้งนะคะโอเค
โอเคพา
ฉันสมัยสายรุ้งเนี่ยมีสี
สวยไหมคะครูฟ้าเก่งมากนะคะเก่งมากนัก
เรียนขอฟังที่ครูหญิงพูดแล้วรู้ไหมว่ามัน
คืออะไร
ถูกหรือผิดนะคะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะ
ส่วนวีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็ต้องไป
ก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ